we begin with breaking developments
germany joins
is the latest to join a growing number
of countries to suspend the rollout
of the astrazeneca covet 19 vaccine over
safety fears
bulgaria denmark ireland the netherlands
norway and iceland
have stopped giving the shot following
reports of an increased risk
of blood clots but astrazeneca and the
world health organization
insist there's no risk the move comes
after a leading german lawmaker called
on the authorities to issue
clear guidance on whether the vaccine is
quote
good or bad
all right let's get you more now i'm
joined by stergyos
he is a virologist and associate
professor at the northumbria
university in the uk a very uh good day
sir
um now i'd like to get your reaction uh
to uh this these
latest developments astrazeneca as you
know insisting there's just
simply no evidence that its vaccine
causes increased risk of blood clots yet
a number of countries
most likely northern european countries
have suspended the use of the vaccine
yeah so i think it we must say first of
all
that it's extremely important when
situations like these arise to take them
very seriously
and have a look at the data very
carefully before jumping to conclusions
we've come into this pandemic through
decades of people
listening to conspiracy theories around
the risks of vaccines with
regards to other diseases so any kind of
wrong message it's actually going to be
very impactful
especially in an effort to try and push
back against this pandemic
so it's really really important that we
give clear concise and carefully thought
out messages so
in that respect i fully support the
decision of any lawmaker
to stop have a look and take into
consideration
the data now on that
data what we know is that 17 million
people have received this vaccine and 37
people have developed these blood clots
that corresponds to 0.0002
of actually anybody that has been
vaccinated getting a blood clot
and you would probably agree with me
that the risk of getting a blood clot
is actually 100 times if not more
less than the risk of actually dying
from coronavirus if you get to get it
therefore to basically be afraid of
something that
may happen because of the vaccine in
order to protect yourself
from something else that can be much
more harmful to you that alone should be
decided to people whether or not they
should take the vaccine
but of course the question is sorry sir
for interrupting me because we have very
limited time together and i'd like to
get as many answers from you as possible
you know obviously yes the chance is
very slim that one
will get a blood clot but if you happen
to be that one person have to
that bad luck that is of course uh not
ideal
um in terms of astrazeneca it's been
it's been
bogged by trust issues not so much in
its vaccine but
in terms of the deal that kind of didn't
went went wayward with
the eu you know what can astrazeneca do
at this stage
to restore confidence in its product
look i don't work for the public
relations department of astrazeneca i'm
here as a scientist
to express my opinion my lended opinion
about the risk that's presented by this
vaccine
and i'm going to put it this way if
somebody came to me through the door
right now said to me
here's the vaccine will you take it i
would say yes please because i'm on the
queue to come in to get the vaccine at
the end of april and that's too far away
as far as i'm concerned
i would take it straight away i would
even give it to my four-year-old child
even though this has not been tested on
children
this is how confident i feel personally
about the risk presented
by these so-called blood clots blood
clots happen in the population randomly
there's a specific number out there
that you can look up which regard with
regards to the frequency of blood clots
in the general population
people that have received the vaccine
seem to be twice less likely to get the
blood clots overall
so from that perspective there is no
risk we really need to make that
abundantly clear
you're joining us sir from the uk where
as i understand astrazeneca is widely
used
share with us some of the experience
that the uk has had with this
a particular inoculation
um what can i say uh obviously many
people would have preferred to receive
one of the vaccines that have a
generally slightly higher
percentage of efficacy but it still is a
very efficacious vaccine we have other
vaccines that have been approved and in
use for decades
that are nowhere near as efficacious as
this vaccine and as a result of that
there should be no concerns and no
hesitancy about receiving the estradical
vaccine
the only individuals that should be a
bit more careful
are the people with uh very strong
allergies and this is just something
general for all medications
i'm sure last time you went to the
doctors and they gave you a prescription
they asked you
are you allergic to anything so if you
are allergic to something
you need to tell the doctor before you
get any vaccine not just this vaccine or
you know the mrna vaccines it's actually
important
that we think about the common good here
and how we can work as individuals to
support
society and the economy in general
all right esther jose
and associate professor at northumbria
university in the uk and molecular
biologist thank you for sharing your
expertise with us
you are welcome all right let's get some
other developments now on the pandemic
the developers of russia's
sputnik v vaccine state companies in
germany france italy and spain
have agreed to help produce the jab it
hasn't officially been approved in the
eu yet though
meanwhile icu doctors here in germany
are urging an
immediate return to a partial log down
because of covet 19 mutations
germany has seen a rise in infections
since gradually easing measures
late last month and half of italy's
regions have gone into a strict lockdown
it's because of a new spike in
coronavirus infections
authorities say hospital admissions are
beyond
manageable
you